all right it is noon central wisconsin
time at least uh don't know what time it
is by everybody else um you know unless
you tell me your time zone and we're
going to do another political theory and
practice discussion
this one is going to be oriented in some
classical political theory but it's
stuff that i've been
reading and thinking about for
about 20 years and finding quite helpful
so it might turn out to be
helpful or useful for some of you and
what i'm referencing is
aristotle's politics i'm also going to
talk a little bit about the nick of
mccain ethics and the rhetoric because
that can often be
quite helpful to compare things to when
you're looking at the politics
but the main thing that i'm i'm
interested in talking about here
is differing conceptions
of justice
the the just and the
unjust which is one of the main
modes for aristotle of what we call
moral
qualities categories right the just and
the unjust the
you know de cayon and anticon
um
we have the beautiful and the ugly the
noble and the base the foul and the fine
however you want to translate the
cologne and ice cream we have the good
per se as the agathon and the bad as the
cocoon we have the useful or the
beneficial and the harmful we have a lot
of other
moral qualities as well and
politics really centers in significant
amount around
what's just what's what's right what is
not just advantageous or profitable the
sum ferron right but the
the just the
the uh unjust who should be rewarded who
should be punished how should we divide
things
and aristotle thinks that this stuff is
pretty complicated and we can go into
some of that in a bit um why it's so
complicated the ambiguity of justice but
i want to start with a passage from his
famous book five which is about stasis
or faction when societies break down
into
their
rival
you can call them factions you can call
them
parties you can call them whatever you
want to
that's what what was a great danger
in greek city-states and not just greek
ones but but others i mean aristotle's
comparative analysis extends beyond the
greek world to carthage and places like
that
and one of the things that he says that
we can really you know take home
and bank has to do with the rich and the
many
so he says
um
[Music]
democracy arose from people thinking
that if they're equal in any respect
they're equal absolutely
for they suppose that because they are
all alike free they are equal absolutely
they're equal in all respects right
oligarchy arose from the assam from
assuming that if they're unequal as
regards some one thing they're unequal
holy for being unequal in property they
assume that they are unequal absolutely
and the oligarchs assume that they're
better of course than everybody else
and then the democrats claim is being
equal to participate in all things and
equal shares while the oligarchs as
being unequal seek to have a larger
share for a larger share is unequal
now here's where it gets really really
interesting aristotle goes on to say
all of these forms of constitution have
some element
of justice they have some degree
of justice
in the greek it's
a decay something some justice right t
dikaion a little bit of it
but from an absolute point of view they
are erroneous that is they're going
astray
and owing to this cause when each of the
two parties has not got the share in the
constitution which accords with the
fundamental assumption that they happen
to entertain class war stasis ensues
and so what is the what is the issue
here
people are mistaken
about um
and they're they're confused about um
[Music]
what justice really consists in
and they
they get something partly right right
there's there's something to their
viewpoint they're not like totally wrong
they're not um
you know absolutely diabolical or
anything like that
but the part that they get right they
blow up into the totality of the only
things that matter
now when you put it that way i think you
can start to see some implications not
just for ancient greece
not just for the ancient world in
general
but for
societies all over the place you can you
can also apply this to relationships
we're not going to worry too much about
personal relationships and this we're
thinking more about society
and the
political right
so
um
that's that's a a key
insight that people are often going to
get things wrong by taking their
perspective as if it's the perspective
and um you know aristotle actually
doesn't say that everybody's perspective
is just as good as everybody else's or
we all need you know something to fill
things in he's not doing the giant thing
about the blind men in the elephant or
anything like that
he's saying listen in society we are
going to have um groups and they are
going to
get things partly right and they're
going to push push push for their point
of view and they're also probably going
to
look at their opponents as
you know trying to do something wrong
and not recognize the rightness in in
their side and we can apply this to many
complex
societal problems now he goes on a
little bit further and he brings in the
other thing that i really want to talk
about in this case
he says
owing to this cause when each of the two
parties has not got the share in the
constitution which accords with the
fundamental assumption the mindset that
they happen to entertain class war
ensues and of all people who excel in
of all people who those who excel in
virtue would most justifiably stir up
faction
though they are the least given to do so
for they alone can with the fullest
reason be deemed absolutely unequal
and there are some men who being
superior in birth claim unequal rights
because they're inequality for people
who have ancestral virtue and wealth
behind them are thought to be noble and
aristotle actually doesn't think that's
the case right he is not a
a um
proponent of dynasty or dunastea in
greek right
so he brings in this this term the
virtuous the the best the aristoi and
you know we need to be very very clear
about what he means in this case in
talking about them he doesn't mean the
people who have money
you can have money and be a total you
know scumbag he doesn't mean the people
who have celebrity he doesn't mean the
people
who even you know have high iq tests or
anything like that he means the people
that have developed
moral virtue and not just whatever
[ __ ] happens to pass for moral
virtue in one's class or one's church or
one's you know school or something like
that real moral virtue the genuine
article which oftentimes is not all that
recognized you know it's very easy to
talk about people being courageous for
the stands they take when a lot of them
are actually cowards genuine courage
according to aristotle should entitle
you to a greater role
in
decision making in the political
community but
and this is a paradox
the people who actually are virtuous and
very often we get mixed up about who
these are you know
the people who genuinely are virtuous
are the ones who have the greatest claim
to
upset the apple cart and rearrange
things so that they're in charge they're
also the least likely to do that why
because they also are the ones who tend
to be the holding the society together
doing the real work behind the scenes
and aristotle is going to talk about
some things you know along these lines
at different points in the politics
particularly in book four
um
[Music]
you know he he talks about
uh
here we go um
we often get mistaken
into thinking that you know there's
there's basically the rich and the the
many or the rich and the poor and he
says the fact that the rich are usually
few and the poor many makes these two
among the parts of the state appear as
opposite sections so that the superior
claims of these classes are even made
guiding principles on which
constitutions and he means like
arrangements now he doesn't mean like a
written constitution like the us
constitution he means the way in which
regimes are structured the politea in
that case it makes that seem to be two
main types and aristotle thinks that's
actually a mistake a little bit later
in it he says there are
three things or three values tria esti
right
um that
have an equal that claim equal
participation in the political
arrangement freedom
everybody's supposed to be free eluteria
right
wealth
um you know or or
property and virtue and then he says for
the fourth what is called nobility
accompanies the two ladder nobility
means ancient wealth and virtue right so
aristotle's kind of analyzing nobility
and then dismissing it in a way that i
think is quite useful and he says
it is manifest that the mixture of the
two factors the rich and the poor ought
to be termed constitutional government
while the mixture of the three factors
deserves the name of aristocracy
most of all the various forms of
aristocracy beside the true and best
form which which is an ideal that isn't
realized anywhere in greece he says at
the time uh you know which would be like
a genuine meritocracy you know when we
use this word meritocracy that's often
an ideological blind for those who were
lucky enough to win the lottery and life
being given the slots right or those who
happen to have found the right
you know buttons to push to get
themselves in as a token of you know
some sort of reparation that has to be
made
we we don't have an awful lot of real
meritocracies out there you know
academia is a prime example i was just
remarking today that you know people who
think that elite institutions and the
people that work at elite institutions
are actually better than other places
just don't have enough experience or
we're blinded by it because people
aren't any smarter at harvard than they
are at marquette university they just
have more prestige they just tell
themselves interesting stories that
other people back up and they have a you
know massive endowment that's not a real
meritocracy a real meritocracy would
involve intellectual virtue and moral
virtue and we would have to have some
way of ensuring and determining that so
that's that's a bit of an ideal we'll
put that to the side aristotle's being
much more realistic about something else
we have to have
some people they're almost like you know
the proverbial biblical
salt of the earth right
we have to have the virtuous within
society and we have to have a certain
number of them or else things are going
to fall apart into
class conflict and war
the virtuous provide the sort of
mediating factor
and what does this mean
well societies that in which the
politics is basically
about competing parties
um that neither you know none of which i
said neither because i'm thinking about
the us situation but we could talk about
parliamentary
systems in which there's you know
multiple parties
unless unless one of those parties
actually contains
you know quite visibly more um
virtuous people which is usually not the
case i mean we can say one party
contains more vicious people um
but
unless we actually see that we're we're
you know we can't vote um simply along
party lines and hope that things are
going to get better and better um
and that you know aristotle would say
that that's a real mistake
he also tends to think um and and maybe
there's something to this that you know
the middle class is where we're actually
going to find
more virtue this is a a classic idea
that runs um
from antiquity all the way into the
present including people by the way like
machiavelli machiavelli thinks that the
rich are always going to be a bunch of
jerks and they're going to try to
humiliate and oppress the poor but you
can't trust the poor either that you
know and we could go on and on and on
with this sort of line but it's
interesting to see this
pointed out
um
he also says that this is another nice
uh
thing
quote by him every state consists of
both quality and quantity by quality i
mean freedom wealth education pidea good
birth and by quantity the superior
numbers of the multitude
and we have to attend to to both of
these these both have to be judged in
comparison with each other he thinks and
so you know what are we
what are we discussing here
you know
if we want a
state especially if we're talking about
something really big like a nation state
which is identified with a certain
culture or set of cultures
and a society and economic systems and
things like that to continue to function
well
or not to just fall apart completely
we
would have to as aristotle says
attend to
how you actually get virtue in there and
how you
keep the people who are basically
non-virtuous or vicious from pushing
their own agendas which could be
economic agendas we just want you know
low taxes so we don't have to pay taxes
or they could be agendas of hate or they
could be agendas of you know sort of
basic foolishness we need to be rivals
to every other country in the world and
have a massive military you know
there could be a lot of ways in which
things go wrong and and people end up
being
vicious and end up enacting policies
that are vicious
probably one of the biggest ones in our
society in american society is
our our lobbying system which allows
corporations to
have
so much sway over both parties
and that makes it very difficult to
enact legislation that would actually be
to the benefit of the people rather than
the benefit of the big donors
and
corporations and things like that
so um
so this is a really interesting idea
that aristotle is putting forward and
aristotle when it comes to politics is
very he's not a realist in the sense of
realist political theory um i actually
think that a lot of realists are quite
quite idealist
but he is realistic
about
what keeps societies functioning
and the need to there and there's no one
single way that you can like turn
attention to virtue any little you know
uh campaign that you would do is always
going to get co-opted by the people who
are non-virtuous
for their their agendas so it requires a
lot of work and it's all really subject
to
um what what you know the ancients
called fortuna
so all right let's let's take some of
these questions i said i would talk for
about 20 minutes and then address
questions and and uh things like that
so a lot of people saying lovely day for
for a lecture it's pretty pretty nice
here in milwaukee
um
darwin says what do you think about the
current crisis on the poland belarus
line i don't actually know enough about
it to think about it i haven't been
looking at it um it looks like it's
belarus manufacturing a crisis
deliberately and belarus has been a bad
actor
you know belarus and its dictator i mean
if you're looking at aristotle what
would belarus be it would be a tyranny
right and it's been a tyranny for for a
long time um basically kept in place as
a satellite state by by putin um
so hopefully you know someday they'll
get a new government
um
all right uh
joe manchin is one of those cowards
masquerading as a courageous moderate
yeah there aren't any courageous
moderates out there right now frankly
most people who call themselves
moderates it's sort of like the
scooby-doo thing you pull off the mask
they turn out to be right-wingers
uh it's unfortunate that the language
has gotten so corrupted and co-opted but
moderate uh constitutional liberal all
those things basically are just you know
um old-school right-wing and and they're
you know they're not that
distinguishable from what the the right
has turned into
in america
um
so mc1 says would the virtuous act
within classes or outside of class
boundaries well both right i mean
it depends on what you mean by within
classes or outside of class boundaries
they are going to be found all over the
place and they may not be able to
coordinate and a lot of their actions
are not going to be like grand political
theater or anything like that it's going
to be doing the right thing
as one of the archons of the city like
you know somebody who like makes sure
that the garbage actually gets picked up
or stuff like that again if you if you
look at aristotle he he gets down to the
nitty-gritty of what um cities need you
know he
in book six for example he goes through
like cities have to have this they have
to have this they have to have this
um
parisia is this from aristotle's book
politics yeah this is this is from the
politics books uh four and book five um
hypatia so few virtuous people left
mostly fanatics and self-serving
manipulators uh i think there's plenty
of virtuous people out there the trouble
is is that we live in a very
uh fragmented society and
you know most times that people
act virtuously they're not doing so to
try to get um
a lot of celebrity or to you know have
have the local news come out and
and see them and um you know the moral
vocabulary as aleister mcintyre has
pointed out has become incredibly
corrupted as well um
so
i think there are plenty of virtuous
people
martin hing the idea that virtuous
people are hiding away from public
discourse seems like wishful thinking i
mean how the hell would you know that
have you done some sort of massive
survey you know i mean to attribute
wishful thinking to somebody when you
don't actually know them is kind of a
funny starter isn't it does aristotle
substantiate these claims claims made
about his own time i mean read the
politics
um
i think you could answer that for
yourself you might want to think about
why why that was your go-to um damon
says aristotle seemed to favor tyranny
completely wrong
um
was he just catering to his sponsors who
do you think his sponsors were i mean at
the time that he's writing this uh is is
alexander the great a massive sponsor
he's actually in disagreement with
alexander about how
alexander ought to treat the persians so
i don't know where you got this idea
that aristotle is a proponent of tyranny
it can't been from reading this book
because
that ain't the case um he's very clearly
in favor of what he's calling aristocrat
aristocracy you know um and he says
tyranny is one of the worst of regimes
so yeah ed uh protocol number one men
with bad instincts are more in number
than the good i don't know what you mean
by protocols but
maybe you're talking about assumptions
um
and aristotle doesn't say that that's
automatically the case it depends on the
society right
um
all right luke says i think it might be
that the virtuous talk less or less
loudly than the self-serving yes and
that is that is part of it
when you look at the motivations that
people have for engaging in
behavior that is not simply self-serving
but helping other people out sometimes
requiring sacrifices i mean doing your
job diligently
inevitably involves sacrifices right
getting into public discussions knowing
what the hell you're talking about uh
not you know just to take a recent
example the washington post published
some [ __ ] claiming who's a princeton
professor claiming that kant is doing
critical race theory and you can't get
any any dumber than that now can you or
lazier as a scholar
you know people who do their due
diligence now we're talking more about
intellectual virtue than moral virtue
but i mean i think lying in public
forums is probably morally vicious right
so it's it's always easier for the the
vicious to do their thing virtue
requires a lot of work and sacrifice and
yeah so
um
[Music]
they're you know the virtuous have less
time to talk about their stuff they're
not always on social media you know um
saying oh i'm so great and this applies
not just to to aristotelian virtue or
platonic virtue but stoic virtue and
christian virtue you know um
you look at like who's singing their own
praises and then who's who's getting
their praises sung by people who
actually know something about it not
just you know a bunch of a bunch of
people who uh
buy their coaching sessions or something
like that right
um
rt whitby do you agree with aristotle
the philosopher would be the best ruler
so aristotle doesn't think that you've
got it mixed up with plato
aristotle actually says in book three
that if you have a person of superlative
virtue and that would you know they
could arguably be a philosopher
you should in fact let them be king
right not tyrant but king but this is
going to pose you with massive
succession problems right because
when you have more representative
government or collaborative government
people are learning how to become
leaders if you just have one person
running the whole show
and then everyone's like okay well this
this person's really the best we're
going to follow along with them
you don't have people being trained up
and aristotle by the way is also not not
a big
fan of hereditary dynasties he thinks
that those are those are problematic as
well
um
all right let's see
mark says do you think aristotelian
notion of
an aristocracy of excellence can be
reconciled with modern notions of
democracy or would it need some
rethinking so both actually i mean
aristotle so this is going to be a bit
of a big picture you know uh thing about
aristotle's works in general
aristotle
is super clear that he is providing us
with outlines he is not providing us
with the total system
we have to do the intellectual work of
filling them in
and a lot of the stuff that he has to
say is under determined and requires us
to engage in some thinking ourselves
which is part of the goal of you know
doing political theory or of doing
ethics or or thinking about you know the
persuasion involved in rhetoric we
shouldn't just be mindless automatons
following a a you know laid out
axiomatic system
we also do have to adapt it to modern
times aristotle's writing
what about now um
20
you know 23 2 400 years ago a lot has
changed even even the the cities that
he's talking about you know maybe he
didn't get them all right in his own
time
so we have to adapt and this is what
people have been doing throughout the
years with with
the aristotelian tradition
so i think both have to to be
done
bottom had one must accept that one
party will always be without virtue
therefore the real concern must be for
the party that could be corrupted the
democratic party is corrupted i don't
know what you're talking about there i
mean the republican party right now is
the party almost entirely lacking in
virtue if you're a republican at this
point in time god help you because you
got to believe so many contradictory
crazy things uh just to like you know
hang out with your fellow nut jobs
the democratic party is corrupt and
there's lots and lots of problems with
it but they're you know at this point in
time
myself as an independent i vote with
them because they're the lesser of the
two
evils and occasionally will even
surprise you right but neither is
particularly
good at this time but we don't have to
accept that one party will always be
without virtue
um i mean we should we should hope for
a two-party or multi-party system in
which both parties actually have some
virtuous people who can hold back the
terrible tendencies that the other
members of the party
are trying to enact and unfortunately
pretty much all you know anybody who had
any virtue in the republican party law
since long since lost it or or left you
know
um
all right don key what about the u.s
founders kind of imagine this will work
if there's no political parties
well the
the u.s the founders were all over the
map they weren't you know this is kind
of an interesting point too
people always like to appeal to the
founders in the semi-religious way who
gives a [ __ ] what they thought right
we're not living in their time we're not
bound by
what they decided you know we shouldn't
have this quasi
you know religious attitude towards them
to begin with and or if we're going to
we should actually
know what the hell they said so we don't
embarrass ourselves claiming all sorts
of things about the founders that the
founders themselves would like you know
if they were here they'd bitch-slap the
people saying it right
um
but the founders were kind of a mix and
a mess right they're all over the map on
this
um you know the federalist papers are
are written partly in response to the
anti-federalist papers right
uh so you know and and they include
everybody from you know very
conservative people to tom payne so i i
don't think that that you know looking
at the founders is particularly
helpful here um
all right ed keeley have you read the
juvenile yeah a long time ago but
you know i don't know how that's
going to be helpful here um
and let's see
all right rt whitby psychologists claim
that people who want to rule others are
in general bad people well i mean any
blanket claim like that about
psychologists is going to be wrong and
i don't see how that's that's
particularly helpful
sometimes wanting to rule people is
actually a great idea i mean think about
the classic thing of i need to be in
charge so other people don't screw it up
even more than they're going to uh you
know the the penalty
for not engaging in politics plato
points this out rousseau points this out
other people pointed out as you leave it
to the dummies to
and the hucksters to decide what's going
to happen
um wanting to exercise power over other
people
you have to ask what is the motive what
are you trying to get out of it could it
be for their benefit could it be just
because you want to make a lot of money
i mean these are very different
ways of doing that
bottom head can't count was racist yeah
who doesn't know that i mean that's
that's pretty much public knowledge at
this time
um so is hegel yeah so what um
so uh
if you read critical theory you're a
conscient that's probably joking around
right because because it's uh uh
kant is not a critical theorist in the
sense that that critical theory is
uh skullgate is the philosopher still
the best ruler in plato's laws or is
that just in the republic also how does
the polity differ from democracy and
prevent tyranny of
demagoguery
um
so i'll answer the the second one
uh when you're talking about polity what
you're talking about is aristotle's sort
of mixed regime how does it differ from
democracy aristotle tells you how the
three good regimes differ from the three
bad regimes so this is a general answer
the three bad regimes are being ruled
for the benefit of those who rule so if
you have a democracy
it's it's um whoever winds up winning
they
arrange things in terms of legislation
and the executive and you know aristotle
wouldn't really worry about the judicial
but we can think about that
uh in this time for their benefit so in
present-day politics you know when the
one party wins they totally reward their
donors and punish you know
the people on the other side and then
you know vice versa aristotle considers
all that degenerate regimes
a
genuine
polity or a good democracy if you want
to use that sort of framework would be
where the rulers who have been elected
by popular um
you know whatever we're going to do it
electorally consent something like that
are ruling for the benefit of the
totality of the
the society which doesn't preclude by
the way you know going after criminals
or um you know taxing people or anything
like that right
um
[Music]
so that that's that's how those differ
how does it prevent tyranny of
demagoguery i mean i don't know what you
mean by tyranny of demagoguery tyranny
is often you know demagogues are often
tyrants right when they get in charge um
but
you know
the polity doesn't prevent it the polity
is a different regime
and so if you want to hold on to that
regime you have to look i mean aristotle
provides you with suggestions about how
you keep regimes from breaking down in
you know books four and book book five
so that's that's where you'd wanna look
at it
all right um
made of clay could we say republicans
are honest or public and they're evil
uh i mean public uh i don't know what
what honest evil means so sure
um ed keeley both parties are completely
controlled and illegitimate that's a
silly thing to say
and if you think the juvenile is more
than applicable in this discussion spell
it out buddy you know because uh it's
been a long time since since i've taken
a look at that
um
mike says was foucault right
in that manner women as a category is
disappearing what do you think
can you tell can you tell whether people
are men or women uh
or or is foucault right that that it's
it's gradually disappearing i mean i
don't really have too much trouble with
that myself maybe it's because i live
here in a you know a less you know
cutting-edge state and city of milwaukee
but
yeah i that that one's kind of a
non-starter there
mark i notice hobbs doesn't make the
distinction between good and bad forms
of constitutions neither does lock why
do you think this distinction was lost
well it was lost in them
it wasn't necessarily lost you know
universally
and you know hobbes is very
anti-aristotelian
he not only is anti-aristotelian he's
also really down on plato and on cicero
he names all three of them as people
whose works should be banned uh by the
the uh commonwealth that would be
dominated by the sovereign in leviathan
right because the the sovereign doesn't
just preserve the peace they also decide
what doctrines can be taught
and uh hobbes thinks that lots of people
are using aristotle for nefarious ends
of faction right
and there's you know there's probably
something to that right you can you can
write about aristotle
and um cherry-pick the stuff and not
really you know deal with politics in a
genuine genuinely aristotelian way you
know aristotle was used for example um
by
um pre-um
pre-civil war um
uh
political theorists in the south not
just to justify slavery but to justify
all sorts of other things as well that
were were quite bad but they were they
were bad aristotle readers you know
deliberately so right um
[Music]
all right uh boy it is really weighing
in with a lot of weird stuff here the
left wants you to think the categories
of men and women are disappearing i
don't know where you're getting this
crap from but you know that's that's
pretty bizarre um i know a lot of people
on the left and they don't seem to want
to think that the categories of men and
women are disappearing so
um
you know if you don't like by the way if
you don't like the comments that i'm
making
you can leave because this is this is
like my front porch here you know
um all right so
massacre what do you think of techno
feudalism that might happen do you think
billionaires should have that much power
especially here
yeah so i think that the corporation
and i think that the
ultra rich
pose new uh problems for
political theory
and this is something very important you
know is the is the corporation something
like a political community if it is then
it's definitely an oligarchy or a
tyranny um very rarely a monarchy or an
aristocracy right
and you know these people that are in
this international super rich who um
very often are driving you know
decisions made by by governments and you
know own media empires and and you know
also
perpetuate themselves over and over
again this is not something radically
new you know my dad when i was a kid had
a book on his shelf called the rich and
the super rich and i remember reading it
when i was in high school and it was
about how like you know the people that
you think are the rich they're not
really that rich there's an entire class
of people they went into incredible
statistical analysis about this that are
managing to like pass on their money and
stuff like that and they they have new
people joining them who own and you know
an innovative company and build it up
and this is very from aristotelian
problem their perspective this is
incredibly problematic right because
they have incredible
uh control
over um
people's uh
uh
destinies i mean
you know and and we have this massive
massive stratification aristotle thought
that that is a sign of a a sick and
dying city state or in his time or
culture and society in our time these
massive
um
you know wealth distinctions which are
also power distinctions i mean somebody
else to look at on that is is rousseau
if you've got money you can
buy power you can buy prestige you know
so this is this is something that we
we do have to to think through
uh hypatia i don't think the younger
generation cares anymore well i mean you
know
these these vast broad generalizations
are almost always false i mean i teach
the younger generation so
my experience is not that they don't
care anymore
my experience is that they often feel
themselves to be
screwed and powerless and and the main
thing that they have to fight against is
despair um
uh rt whitby did aristotle think that
having power leads to becoming vicious
no uh he doesn't think that there's sort
of an automatic progression from gaining
power to being vicious but he does think
that if you are vicious or have
tendencies towards it
he actually talks about um being a
craddock you know having a loss or lack
of control
in book four
um if you're given power you're probably
going to screw up and you're and that's
going to be bad not just for you and not
just for your immediate let's call them
victims the people that you're doing
injustice to that's going to be bad for
society in general so
you can have
good people get into power and then they
can you know they can fix things they
can make things better not not like a
utopian way but
to some degree making things better and
that's what aristotle really wants to
see happening in cities and by the way
he says in the politics and he is the
guy who like did
uh empirical studies of all these greek
city-states he says
not a single one of them
is really a well-run city at this point
you know that's that's sobering isn't it
so
um
oh here's an interesting thing from from
mc1
do you think rawls successfully
reconciles meritocracy and equality
um
i mean in theory yes
but
when are we ever placed in something
like a rawlsian
um
veil of ignorance
where we would you know then
go through this experiment and choose
the difference principle and you know uh
when i try it out with my classes i
don't get the results that rawls does
which tells me a lot that like either
rawls is kind of making it up or it has
something to do more with like doing
doing experiment thought experiments
like that with students at elite schools
who are not representative of students
you know worldwide
um i mean it's it rawls is enunciating
something that really sounds awesome
doesn't it you know we have a fairly
equal um society with respect to
opportunity
and other things and then we have
differences between people we have
inequalities but they're not going to be
like massive inequalities and they're
they're you know
they're basically open to anybody to get
in there so the doctor can get paid more
than the uh
the orderly because the doctor is you
know it's to the benefit of the society
and it's also to the benefit of the
worst off that's another key thing in
rawls's approach
but we almost never see anything like
that unfortunately you know
so
all right emily what is justice and do
you think the pre-socratic can help us
in finding guidance for political
formation so
aristotle who we're talking about here
says that justice is something that has
multiple meanings and this is why we get
so so you know screwed up about it if
you want to look at what aristotle some
of what aristotle says about justice you
want to go to nica mccain ethics book
five
and then you want to supplement it with
what he says in the politics and what he
says
in parts of the rhetoric and other parts
obviously of the nico mccain and
eudaimian ethics
justice is polysemis it's ambiguous it
has a number of different meanings so
there isn't any what is justice there's
what are the different kinds of justice
um
[Music]
and
do i think the pre-socratics can help us
in finding guidance not at all i don't i
don't think the pre-socratics have uh
much to offer us on that with the
exception of maybe solon you know if you
want to lump him in there he's got some
good stuff in his poems
you know
that that he says about about um justice
in the city and stuff like that but most
of what we have from the pre-socratics
is fragmentary
and isn't isn't really focused on on
politics it's focused on
you know you have to pick one thing it's
focused on metaphysics right so
there isn't that much to work with you
know people find the pre-socratics kind
of
sexy because they're ambiguous and you
can make all sorts of cool stuff out of
them but so much of it is very
speculative that's why we read people
like aristotle or plato or seneca or
cicero or you know these other these
other great thinkers because we have
their stuff you know
mike did marxist and fascists fit into
the left right liberal paradigm or
should they be considered separate from
it neither in both kind of
you know
people like to sometimes so like when i
was in high school
here's what they would do they would say
we've got a political spectrum and it's
like a line right and in the middle
obviously are like moderates and then we
have liberals and we have conservatives
and then we have radicals and we have
reactionaries and you know reactionary
as well you know the fascists would fit
in there and socialists or marxists or
pick whatever else they would be
radicals right
and
that's a nice story we tell ourselves
but things are
of course way more complicated than that
i mean in general fascists are on the
right sometimes they have policies
or or use language that is of the left
but they're usually persecuting people
on the left so that should tell you what
the hell is going on
um
and you know if a marxist is somehow on
the right i think they probably at some
point quit being a marxist right
uh so yeah
um
pif falls says should our political
disagreement play out in an agonistic
setting well
as opposed to what i mean it always does
play out in an agonistic
setting um wouldn't it be nice if things
were less agonistic
yeah um but even like you know even
going so we're really in a bad way here
in america now or things are very
polarized um compared to like you know
what i can remember from the 70s and the
80s and they were polarized then as well
but not to the degree they are now
but it was still really agonistic back
then
so i you know i don't know
i mean maybe if we're talking about
local politics
it's not quite so agonistic at least in
some places
um
but it's kind of tough to
to uh
imagine a politics that that wouldn't be
you know
um
here's here's a good one um
from mark should we eat the rich was
aerosmith right i think motorhead has an
eat the rich too right
um and so does crocus i think it's kind
of a popular um
theme at least in metal i don't know if
it is in other other genres
but uh should we eat the rich
um
i mean assuming that we resorted to
cannibalism
um
they might not be you know they might
not be very healthy to eat
then again you know some of them have
pretty good hygiene and
and uh
health care and stuff like that so i
don't know i mean you know here we get
into a lot of practicalities i mean what
we ought to do is we ought to tax the
rich fairly right we we really ought to
get rid of all these these dodges that
people use um to you know because when
taxes are not distributed fairly they're
going to get distributed on somebody and
they they wind up hitting the poor
and the middle class what there is still
of it much much harder and it makes it
difficult to have any real social
mobility um
and um it creates a lot of injustices
you know if you think about what led to
the french revolution one major thing
that led to it was was that taxes were
basically displaced from the upper
classes on to the lower classes on on
things like salt you know
or the number of windows that you'd have
in your house so they promoted some very
unhealthy ways of living and they you
know people lost a lot of what they
they would have
um
made of clay says why do conspiracy why
do conservatives fall into conspiracy at
least in today's political climate
that's a great question i don't i don't
actually have a great answer for that
all i all i see is the train wreck of it
happening and you know we're dealing
with the covid pandemic and we're
dealing with an earlier
uh pandemic of viruses that have gotten
into people's minds and and turned them
into you know in some cases
unrecognizable caricatures of who they
were i i know a lot of people who at one
time were decent people who i went to
school with or were colleagues and they
bought into all this you know right wing
conspiracy crap
and you know it wasn't all like in one
fell swoop but they become fairly
unrecognizable as the people that they
once were
and you look at them and you're like
jesus what the
this you know you poor bastards except
that they're not just poor bastards
they're now like deliberately doing this
there's a kind of viciousness
to it um
and that's that's really
it's really troubling
um i don't know how we how we
move past that and i think that's part
of why
our our society american society is
pretty well screwed
um
going forward you know
i don't think we're going to get out of
this this kind of
morass that we're in
um
let's see here
rishba says who is your favorite
american founder best political
philosopher
i mean i don't think i have a favorite
founder i teach them sometimes when i
teach american philosophy as part of the
you know what we call the american
renaissance
but i don't think i have a favorite
founder
um
so mark asks about ubuntu uh what how
much do you know about ubuntu some but
not not you know it's not like a major
area of study but i had i was sort of
like mandated to teach it in some
classes so i had to to beef up my my
knowledge of it i think there's some
interesting intersections between it and
some concepts and classical greek
philosophies
i would say that's right
um
and uh
you know it's it's it's often and mark
and i have talked about this before
it's often portrayed as if it's like the
african ethics when really africa is a
very you know diverse place
um
so
william will tool democracy is declining
do you think this is true uh yeah i
would say that is true and democracy has
been declining
for decades
and it's i mean it's interesting because
we have places that when i was a kid
were definitely not democracies and then
were able to become
democracies or were assimilated into
democracies if you think about
the
east german
state under the communists right it
became part of
west germany and then you know just
became germany and germany is a
functioning democracy it's got its
challenges of course but
um that that happened i mean other other
places
that were behind the warsaw pact you
know what we call the iron curtain have
become
more or less
functioning
but sometimes not very functioning i
mean look at um
uh orban in in hungary
hungarian civil society has been gutted
over the last
10 years
[Music]
and it's you know it's it's a
disheartening to see
but it's not as if like democracy itself
is just
one single thing i mean it can be at a
lot of different levels
so
all right
uh paul says should we use the moral
standards of the historical time period
of any particular thinker
as a guide to their ideas or should we
apply present-day standards to popular
historical thinkers both why wouldn't we
do both and why wouldn't we try to
harmonize between them it's not an
either or
um sort of sort of thing
um it's really interesting because
people say oh you know aristotle
couldn't have been against slavery
because uh you know that was just the
common idea at the time and then
obviously they haven't read
politics book one where aristotle says
now some people say that all slavery is
against nature and therefore unjust
right there were people at the time they
just weren't they weren't um popular uh
uh decision makers or thinkers or stuff
like that
he doesn't name who they were and we
don't know how many they were so i mean
we can we can judge from all different
perspectives the problem the issue is
when we're making judgments are they
[ __ ] judgments do we have anything
to back them up you know are they uh
just serving our own purposes our
rhetorical purposes
it's not just so like uh either we judge
by their own time standards which are
probably uh uh you know there's a lot of
controversy there or we judge from the
present we have to go deeper i think
um
[Music]
let's see here
peter heil says what do you think of uh
vara focuses statement we don't live
under capitalism we live in techno
feudalism where socialism is for the
rich again massively sweeping statement
i don't usually buy into those too much
i mean
it depends on what you mean by
techno-feudalism techno-feudalism isn't
entirely without capitalism
um i just don't find these to be
particularly
helpful ways of talking about things in
the present you know
you know as time is going on i become
much more of a
well let's actually look at what's going
on here and then describe what's going
on here can you can you say the same
things about the united states as you
can about indonesia
as you can about
the people's republic of china as you
can about saudi arabia as you can about
brazil
you know can you make the same sweeping
assertions about all of these at the
same time
i don't know you know
i mean people will say yes
neo-liberalism but that i mean when you
get that broad it doesn't actually mean
much of anything right
um
[Music]
rodrigo can you talk a bit about the
difference between bios and zoe and
aristotle and the relation of these two
terms the being of the political animal
i think this is overblown um
bios just means a way of life you know
zoe means an animal right uh there are
some thinkers who have like tried to
turn them into you know massively
different categories but that's not
that's not aristotle
um aristotle is concerned about the
light you know life and what what its
conditions are and then the the good
life right
um and we are
one animal among many we are the animal
that is uh you know politike
but we're also the one that's um
rational and able to you know again read
politics book one we're able to
participate in
uh to form you know communities based on
moral values uh in ways that other
animals can't right
um
let's see
says i think the way nowadays we
understand liberty or freedom has become
a problem i would love to practice the
way aristotle understands human virtues
yes and freedom is one of those terms
like justice that is highly ambiguous
and i think
that there is a pernicious kind of
freedom a conception of freedom as
basically i get to do whatever the hell
i want because i'm you know a good
person in privilege and everybody else
should like you know they can do what
they want so long as it doesn't impinge
on me so don't like make me you know i
want police protection but don't tax me
you know um i i get to shoot anybody who
comes in my yard and i get to claim that
you know people are hurting me with what
they're saying but i don't i don't give
that to anybody else it's this kind of
screw you i've got mine freedom
and i'm i'm tempted to think that it's
you know american in origin
but it isn't really i think that there's
[ __ ] like that throughout the world
throughout time but it's become
particularly centered in
this uh american you know this appeal to
like freedom and you know liberty and
all that on the part of people
who
don't care about other people and often
want to try to screw them over if they
can um
so i think there's something there's
something behind that but i think you
can see that a lot in in the tories in
britain at this point in time and
actually a lot of labor people in
britain too particularly their
leadership and you see this a lot among
among um
you know people in the business world
um
[Music]
so
that's not the only conception of
freedom that we have but it's somehow
becoming the one that dominates the
discourse
so i think we have a lot to
to
work at on that so i think that's a good
insight
um
quantum astrologer is there even a set
of values laws and economic paradigms
which account for the needs of all
humans and nature
why is the dictatorship under a strong
super computer our only chance well i
don't know that that's the case i mean
that's a non-starter right there i want
to talk about a loaded question right
uh yeah there's plenty of sets of values
laws you know i don't know about
economic paradigms but
we're always working at it and i think
that virtue ethics provides us with a
lot of useful
components for that is there like a
single book that contains all of it i
don't think so you know
um
[Music]
let's see here
uh dr wrightlife have you read dark
persuasion or twilight of democracy i
haven't um also do you recommend you two
sites sovereign nations and new disks
wow
new discourses lindsay um i mean would i
recommend him yeah i'd recommend you
don't watch his crap because he's an
idiot
or at least at least he's playing an
idiot on tv because holy [ __ ] does that
guy say stupid stuff you know
um so
i mean if you are into those kind of
people this probably isn't for you you
know
you gotta wean yourself off of that that
silly crap before you're gonna get
anything out of reading like aristotle
um
so all right uh
james who do you find to be the most
compelling character in plato's republic
i mean i don't find characters
compelling in dialogues
i'm not sure how how that would work
if you ask me about novels i could tell
you
massacre how should we view human beings
when should we use hermeneutics
phenomenology post-structuralism
structural functionism etc well i mean
maybe after you've spent a lot of time
hanging out with people before you start
you know getting into all these isms and
have a good sense of like
human psychology and how things work and
you've got some relationships formed i
mean i don't know that that
bringing hermeneutics to bear is
automatically going to be very helpful
for understanding human beings unless
you can connect it to the experiences
that you actually have i don't think
that there's any any answer to that
thomas says do you think the usa is too
large to govern does aristotle address
the governability of state under this
aspect the united states and actually i
mean almost every country that exists
right now
is way way bigger than what aristotle
was envisioning
i mean he did have a little bit of input
into
alexander's conquests right
um
but the stuff that aristotle had to say
doesn't seem to be particularly
on point or helpful you know he
basically said
alexander this is a letter from plutarch
which may or may not be genuine right
says alexander you're screwing up you're
treating these persians as if they're
not automatically slavish people so
you're showing some real ethnocentrism
there which which by the way shows up in
the politics right
alexander was in some respects more
enlightened than aristotle in in his
treatment of the conquered peoples and
trying to form this this empire um
does that mean that we can't use
aristotle to understand things no it
means that aristotle himself
is not particularly helpful on that
um
all right i'm gonna have to get going
soon because i gotta
do some other
recording in a bit
let's see what we have here
um
cola moose says any suggestions for how
to incorporate aristotelian ideas about
politics in a sci-fi story
that's interesting um i don't have any
like
general
helpful suggestions i i would say um and
i think you could say this about any
if you're writing a sci-fi story um
and you want to incorporate some
philosophy into it there's a couple ways
you can do it one is you can like
deliberately weave in
the thing as like
something that you study or some some
some technology that you you use right
um
or
some
discipline
and i mean you could have like somebody
talking about aristotelian rhetoric
so you can do what like dostoyevsky does
in his novels which is has people talk
philosophy right
and
you could have like two people on a
spaceship talking about aristotle's
politics and saying oh you know this is
all kind of psa because you know we all
live under a totalitarian society but
isn't it cool to think about the idea
that there could be you know six regimes
or something like that
the other thing you could do i guess
would be to
like think about the broader
topics and then think about how you
could weave them in in a more subtle
more global way
when i was in grad school i actually had
this uh
this uh pipe dream of writing a
novel about a detective who would be the
aristotelian and he would apply like
aristotelian principles in a very
flexible way
um not in a schematic way to like solve
crimes and stuff like that i never did
anything on it of course because i'm not
i'm not a fiction writer so
yeah
but that's actually kind of an
interesting idea um
skulls gate do you teach plato's laws no
i i generally i mean the the books that
i teach by plato in my classes are
uh apology
occasionally the credo sometimes the
euthyphro the fado bits of the republic
the symposium
um
every once in a while the gorgeous you
know i i don't i don't teach
uh at a place where i would be teaching
like graduate students and we would
focus just on one text like the laws
um
mark has an interesting suggestion here
a sci-fi version of the name of the rose
where they're hunting for the other part
of the poetics that's been lost in the
in the future yeah
that could be quite awesome um just
don't give it to hollywood to screw it
up right
um
[Music]
all right uh
rodrigo asked do you think with
modernity we lost an important sense of
the telos of the political community we
need to recuperate if so is it possible
under the secular nation state
um
yeah possible under the secular nation
state probably not going to come from
the secular nation state did we lose
something yeah we are always losing
something but we shouldn't romanticize
the past i mean if you were a slave in
athens um the wonderful athenian
democracy was not you know this awesome
thing that you were like a little bit of
it it probably sucked for you you know
especially if you were like working in
in uh a profession that was going to
kill you 20 years younger then then you
should so um i mean we we always lose
things modernity is too big of a thing
to say
blanket across the board um that this is
gone or this is gone or this is gone you
know we we
again i think we have to specify a lot
more
all right um
so i'm going to bring this to a
a close
and uh
thank everybody for
further questions comments
some you know better than others
guaranteed but
you know
discourse is important dialogue is
important
like epictetus says entering into the
hall of the philosophers like going into
a doctor's office you know don't expect
it to be necessarily the most fun
experience in the world
right
so
um
we'll do another one of these next month
i'll think about what topic i'm going to
do
and uh got a couple other things coming
up later in the month classic metal
class of course next
next
saturday if i get around to it uh
speculative fiction studies
on anathem
um hopefully i'll i'll get that
otherwise i may have to put that off
till next month and uh i'll see all of
you somewhere in the
ether